اصدر القضاء التونسي مذكرات ضبط واحضار
بحق شخصين موجودين خارج البلاد احدهما نجل
رئيس حركه النهضه معاذ الغنوشي في قضيه
تكوين مجموعه من اجل تغيير شكل الدوله
والاعتداء على الامن الداخلي واثاره
الفوضى بين السكان
معنا من تونس مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه وليد
عبد الله وليد يعني تفاصيل ما ورد بهذا
الخبر معك تفضل
مساء الخير تفاصيل الخبر تؤكد ان وكيل
الجمهوريه نطق الرسمي باسم المحكمه
الابتدائيه في محافظه القصرين الحدوديه مع
الجزائر اعلن واكد ان السلطات القضائيه
التونسيه
اصدرت بالطاقه جلب وتفتيش في حق نجل راشد
الغنوشي معاذ الغنوشي بتهمه تكوين وفاق من
اجل الاعتداء على امن الدوله
الداخليه وتبديل هيئه الدوله وحمل السكان
على مهاجمه بعضهم بعض واثاره الهرج
والبلبله هذه هي التهمه الموجهه لراش
الدولي راشد الغنوشي معاذ الغنوشي لماذا
بطاقه الجلب لسبب بسيط لان معاذ الغنوشي
هو الان خارجه حدود الوطن وبالتالي من
بارد جدا ان السلطات التونسيه قد تكون
وجهه مذكره الى الشرطه الجنائيه الدوليه
الانتربول لجلب معاذ الغنوشي للتحقيق معه
في تونس على اعتبار انه غادر البلاد قبل
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في الخامس والعشرين
من يوليو يتنقل وفق مصادقتنا بين انجلترا
التي يحمل جنسيتها وسويسرا
والتركيا وتعود اصول القضيه الى نهايه
الشهر شهر 10 تحديدا يوم العشرين منه
حينما فتحت انياب العموميه بحثا تحقيقها
ضد اربعه اشخاص بتهمه تلقي اموال وتوزيعها
لاثاره البلبله في محافظه القصرين على
خلفيه الاحتجاجات حول عدم توفر المواد
الاستهلاكيه وان من بين هذه المجموعه نجوى
رئيس برلمان سابق وايضا رئيس حزب سياسي
سابقا
معاذ الغنوش اذا الشبه تتحول الى التهمه
ويبدو انك تحقيقه على كل حال عبد الله
سنبقى نتابع معك يعني وليد عفوا سنبقى
نتابع معك تفاصيل هذه القضيه وما سينتج
عنها بالايام والساعات المقبله شكرا لك